[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مايو ويونيو ويويو هذه الازمنه التي تقام
فيها كاس العالم منذ انشائه قبل 92 سنه
1930 وهذه السنه اقيم كاس العالم في اواخر
شهر نوفمبر الى منتصف شهر ديسمبر كاول
بطوله في التاريخ تقام خلال هذا التوقيت
ليش لانقر البلد المستضيف تكون درجه
حرارتها عاليه في التواريخ المتعارف عليها
مايو ويويو بما يعرف عندهم بذابحت وجمره
البيض وهي الفتره التي ينافس فيها الخليج
بلدان العالم على الدرجه الاحمر وفي اواخر
موسم واول الموسم المربعانيه كحالي ايامنا
هذه تكون بلدان الخليج درجه حرارتها هي
الالطف على مستوى العالم متميز بين الجمال
فوق الجمالي
جميله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وكاس العالم بدا موسم برد الحيمر وهالقطر
يسمونه ضربه لحيمر وهي سبعه ايام خلالها
تهب علينا رياح شماليه بارده تجبر الناس
على اي ارتدوا ملابس الشتاء الثقيله على
شمال السعوديه وكذلك الكويت وينتهي كاس
العالم اذا تصفت المربعانيه وهو موسم
البرد الفعلي على جل البلدان العربيه من
البرد في ضلع الليالي بدايحين يشبه فراد
لا ضمها الشوق كل الحزين اللي اخفاء دمعه
العين ثم البكاء
وختامى ونقول الله يوفق السعوديه وقطر
وتونس والمغرب بكاس العالم وان شاء الله
انهم بيشرفون كل العرب ودمدم
[موسيقى]